everyone has a story you're gonna fall
right out of your seat but some stories
are so incredible
they deserve to be immortalized on
television what genre would you call
this story or a mystery action
inspirational join ed helms and randall
park where and when does this story
begin in nebraska alexandria virginia as
they hear ordinary people hi how's it
going tell extraordinary true stories
and i just said
count me in
wait a minute wait a minute hold on i
thought you were dungeons and dragons
guys
then bring them to life with a
star-studded cast pretty incredible huh
my parents were extremely strict hey yo
have fun tonight ronald what fun at this
hour have fun you're like be cool
i never liked him
bad influence yeah he's not even saved
yeah
what if you guys tried being me for a
day they're like oh like real smart and
weird no i was thinking more so
i am blown away
you are an incredible person what do you
think about going down and getting the
football he says one of the dumbest
things i've ever heard your immediate
response is that's a great idea i see
this beautiful girl she was just glowing
i kept looking at her a little bit too
much
remember that
who the frigg are you i would punch you
in your stupid face but i don't want to
get grease on my new championship ring
story's so amazing it wasn't allergic
reaction they're very poisonous
so dramatic is he gonna propose to me so
ridiculous literal projectile vomit so
unbelievable they could only be true you
snuck in the super bowl all the way to
the bus bus guy opens the door bradshaw
is right in front of me you guys are
badass that was the best game i ever
seen
who was that i think that was the
coach's nephew maybe
and that's the end of my story that's my
story brothers that's the story guys
true story with edin randall
you